was ist das ja du lukas da war noch was
ich dir sagen wollte herzlich konzern
die leute schön dass wir eingeschaltet
habe eigentlich leute eigentlich wollte
ich die anzahl der hilfen videos auf
einem kanal ein bisschen runterfahren
weil wir schon fast alles was es auf der
welt überhaupt noch geben kann er hilft
mir konnte auf diesem kanal schon
analysiert uns lächerliche gezogen haben
aber aber dann ist mir ein video über
den weg gelaufen was allein schon von
titel und kanten erklärt nicht
lächerlicher sein könnte alles wirklich
haarsträubend
es ist wirklich hart ich lese ich meine
titel vor und wendet es später zu allen
denn dieses video heißt das schwarze
baby das schwarze wii ist dass meine
tochter
naja wir weiter sind das noch
da sehen wir die ausgangssituation wir
haben zwei junge menschen relativ junger
menschen die dafür heißt sarah aus der
beschreibung mitnehmen können und ihr
verlobter heißt lukas die beiden
erwarten baby naw als ich gefragt habe
was diese schwersten in der zahnmedizin
verschluckt die alte ist tatsächlich
schwanger oder das alte rathaus gott ich
wollte sagen
die liebe nette ist schwanger und wir
machen weiter mit der keiner vorstellung
diese nette damen ii erscheint heike zu
sein also die mutter der schülerin bzw
den medizinball verschlucken ok alles
klar gut dann komm wir sind jetzt quasi
wie geht's sind sie ja vater ja ich bin
der vater
also sollte die jetzt schwer sein sollte
da wirklich was aus dem bauch raus
kommen dann bin ich auf jeden fall nicht
derjenige der das da rein gemacht hat ok
also ich bin auch nicht zuständig für
mich unter als zahle oder muss mich auch
nicht um das kind kümmern ich bleibe nur
zufällig der einzige mann im richtigen
alter
in diesem krankenhaus gerade er kann
sich ja jedes mädchen so einen jungen
wie lukas wünschen es gibt ja andere die
wollen doch gar nicht dazu stehen oder
würden
erst mal was ist da los ja ja ja wir
kennen sie alle die kennen sie alle die
jungen peter oder auch alten täter die
in dem moment wo es die eigene freundin
oder frau schwanger ist und in den
kreißsaal gefahren sind um zu entbinden
erstmals sind so ach so da kommen jetzt
raus ich dachte er hinzu dafür würde ein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kleines mädchen ist es geworden nur ja
was fehlt einfach sagen wollten sie sind
sind bei hilf mir dass es so eine rtl 2
format und ja wir sind dafür bekannt
dass wir immer die geisteskranken videos
aus youtube haben und deswegen ist er
kennt jetzt schwarz wollte nur sagen
haben ja das mit dem der arzt merck so
die farbe passt genießen das kann als
ich mich vor dem vater sein und ist
welches kind kind will was ich wollte
dass ich schwanger war
es ist doch nicht reichen doch als ich
meine wir haben alle sarah wir haben
alle zu gesehen also meine zuschauer
dort rennen am ring leute hey leute
sarah sarah leute ja doch das kann man
muss dir raus sein kind ja also das
heißt falls wir ausschließen dass der
arzt zufällig in kind gelegt hat einfach
so ohne schwanger zu sein als man also
wenn du das erste mal dein baby siehst
du schreist das ist nicht mein kind also
ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt warum es
nicht ihr kind ist liebe hilfe expertin
schaut mal nach unten
es ist nicht so schwierig die hat
besitzt da schaut einfach mal ein
bisschen nach unten rechts von mir würde
es nur die augen aufmachen würdest du
sehen dass da steht das schwarze baby
und wenn sie halt kann nicht schwarz ist
und ihr freund auch nicht schwarz ist
dann halt ein schwarzbier dabei
rauskommt ist mir so ein fragezeichen im
raum
was ist das denn ist doch versüßt photos
coupe hatte sich selber vor leute so das
passiert wirklich seine echten leben
sagt mutter und vater sind quasi
mitteleuropäer helle haut und dann soll
das kind ist halt schwarz so und dann
die mutter wird naja du lukas da war
noch was ich dir sagen wollte ist dass
das baby das passiert wenn man mit
frauen liebe macht genau weißt schon
dann kommt man stolz und bringt diese
kleinen dinge die werden immer noch ein
normaler mensch also diese kleine zu
schreiben aber keine sorge gibt ein
bisschen zeit gibt den setzt sich gegen
andere pokémon ein level die auto und
werden wir mal erwachsen was ist dass
sie schwarz ich meine da könnte es immer
noch leute und die könnte immer so
farbenblind war wusste ich mal in lukas
lage versetzen lukas hat blaue augen
lukas ist hellhäutig die mutter ist
jetzt auch hellhäutig und das kind ist
schwarz
ja kein unlösbares problem muss man dazu
sagen sagt warum aber ist im ersten mit
erst ein bisschen
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich bin
nicht ganz im bilde mit mit hautfarben
die hautfarben vererbt werden aber es
gibt in der gen theorie die jetzt auch
nichts mehr angehen und das ist echt
langweilig dass ein bio gelernt habe
aber es gibt glaube ich so was wie
dominante und rezessive anleger also
merkmale die sich durchsetzen und nicht
durchsetzen es kann sein dass man so
merkmale wie hautfarbe in seinen genen
hat aber das ist durch andere merkmale
überlagert wird und dann immer eine
gewisse kombination von genmaterial von
vater mutter zusammenkommt kann dann das
kind theoretisch auch schwarz-weißen
eltern auch ohne frage gehen aber da
sind wir ganz ehrlich das wäre wäre zu
vernünftig verhelfen jetzt kein design
die tochter ist schwarz ist supersüß
ganz lieb kann aber leider nicht von
lukas seien und dass das wirklich nicht
also wie gesagt leute ich hab nur jetzt
mal so gefühlt style mit bio wissen was
ich vor acht jahren in der schule
gelernt aber sowas aber also ich würde
es jetzt auch so stand jetzt nicht
ausschließen dass es möglich ist
irgendwann von euch wird es besser
wissen wie das ist keine kommentare
schreiben und leicht an hochegger
personal hat ich meine ist es möglich
und ich also ich meine ich bin
irgendeinem youtube also das ist ja die
hilfen experten also eigentlich alles
besser wird natürlich
es ist wirklich schwach hauptsache
gesund egal ob schwarz oder weiß
ich bin genervt weiter was soll der
scheiß man findet man sich so an mein
kind nicht die rote farbe mit der ich
gerechnet habe toll
juckt mich das nicht so ein theater her
das wäre ganz baby schwarzes oder grün
lila ist das so ja ich war den ganzen
tag mit einem lkw durch europa um kohle
nach hause zu bringen und du hast nichts
besseres zu tun hat wieder mal zu hören
ja jetzt ja jetzt kommen jetzt
tatsächlich an den partys in diesem
video handelt die möglicherweise etwas
unangenehmer sein könnte also sollte als
benötigt gespannt wie wir das auch
müssen meinst du mir fällt es nicht
konnte doch nicht
[Musik]
ja ich habe gab es fällt ähnlich aus
ja es ist ja es ist aufgefallen
natürlich nicht direkt dachte könnt ihr
einfach ein schwarzes kind unter jubel
werden beide eltern weiß und du wirst
dann zu dumm da für mich selbst etwas zu
einer aktivierung schmerzen hier
sie hat mit mir umgeht ob bio bio also
leute ich kann das jetzt gerade nicht so
gut weg doch kann ich warte ich googles
gerade hier kann ein kind schwarzen wenn
beide eltern dafür ist es dort von der
welt über eine frau in südafrika wurde
das schwarze und weiße eltern geboren
über generationen hatte das genetische
material geschlummert rennen youtuber
wusste es besser als die expertin
also sarah ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich finde das ist der wahnsinn also das
kind ist schwarz und du erzählst aber
trotzdem dass ich mit keinem anderen
mann oder du hast mit keinem anderen
mann geschlagen
wir müssen die kritischen formulierungen
wahrscheinlich erzählt sarah dass du die
hilfe experte wird keinem anderen mann
geschlafen hast du die hilfen expert ist
so etwas habe ich wohl leiter wenn ich
irgendwas finde ich wollte ich gerade in
schutz nehmen ok mit irgendwelchen
erzählungen bio unterricht und sachen
wie möglicherweise nötig sein könnten ja
das ist nicht mein lieblingsthema etwas
gemacht und sich zu schützen sarah okay
ich hätte die bio karte für dich
gespielt okay ich habe es durchgezogen
aber wenn du dich so dumm anstellt kann
ich auch nicht helfen wenn sie leben
leute und ich hab ich habe vor gespielt
haben wir für euch
und ja es scheint alles ist so als hätte
er zwei die folge einfach abgeschnitten
bevor klar wird ob er wirklich der vater
ist dieser lukas nicht unbedingt die
klügste entscheidung aber das was man
zum ausflug in den themenbereich der
babys mit der falsche farbe und der
biologie betrieben vorgeschlagen sind
gefragt hier oben könnt ihr mein klarer
werden durch dieses video gefallen hat
wird es mich sehr freuen wenn es machen
würdet und ja wir sehen uns in zwei
tagen wieder mit dem nächsten video
leute ich kurz vor augen
macht's gut